[Music]
my calcium is after chain
Oh No
[Music]
smash like on this video right now if
you drink milk
that's right this video is sponsored by
boo milk Thank You milk for sponsoring
this video nipple has calcium in it
it's October's where the fret girl if
spooky means guys let's just jump into
it when CVS runs out of calcium pills ro
if you see this image while watching me
review you have been visited by the
clapping Peru Peruvian flute skeleton
guard bronze and calcium will come to
you by only if you comment down below
gracias in your escuela though hey hey
guys remember this kid you still think
you're not convinced of our sponsor you
think calcium is for suckers
this is him after just one glass of milk
imagine what 10 glasses of milk will do
don't even imagine it
your head might explode her come over
him no I'm too spooked it spooked Ober
her I have a calcium have you ever
experienced calcium
symptoms include intense feeling of
brown I can look at my podium badge you
can also win an iPod - alright that's a
great deal bones in urine have you tried
it stop judging if you haven't tried it
I'm so sick of all you prejudiced
commenters me I just get acne before
most what are you gonna do drink soy
like a little soup board
ooh sorry bye on that shy boy alert this
guy doesn't drink calcium
he drinks soy pathetic
today's video is sponsored by mr.
Skelton
Thank You mr. skeltal for sponsoring
this video literally no one else will
but he reached out his helping hand and
it feels good what a lot of people don't
realize is calcium is metal you got it
resting spaghetti Pompey you never
forget e that's right if your drink
calcium your body will be preserved
forever how awesome is that smash like
if you think that's awesome
who are you and why oh right so a lot of
people have been asking me if it looks
how did the universe get created well
here you go
Holmes are you and wide musk you acquire
calcium Mayan milk elements such as this
is rare commodity friend I would it
would be unwise to challenge me witness
their potential absorbed and that means
was created remember there was a time on
the internet before memes this is how it
looked like miss slay low-fat give me
that full fat milk thank you very much
damn Dave yes slurp ah let's roll zero
damage cling cling cling cling zero
damage zero damage zero damage zero
damage haha oh yes
drink milk everybody's supposed to buy
milk check out the referral link down
below I get two hundred dollars for
everyone that signs up for my milk class
getting your calcium from drinking milk
getting your calcium from taking
multivitamin
and getting calcium by just straight-up
eating chalk top getting all of your
calcium by upvoting through this video
that's right everybody that's where
that's in calcium means gets rattled
everybody how long is this man gonna
last it's almost like we can't even last
through October 4 spooked Ober memes
they're already named Undead memes are
literally dying that's how bad this is
the fact that no one has made a meme out
of means dying is beyond me
cuz that's the situation we killed
spooked Oberer and calcium memes in one
week
nice nice rap now some people have been
judging me review this is not fair just
because I review the memes and explain
the joke to a large audience of people
doesn't mean I've ruined the joke okay
all right Felix
we need more of spooky memes I got you
fam don't you worry
Barnacle Boy
[Music]
[Applause]
I freakin love science Sam Smith is
what's gonna save it spooked over of
course of course of course my boards
Spence hey Chris you think it's safe to
drink from a fire hose
why not yet it's just water alright we
turn it on I'm very thirsty Jesus of
October okay basically that was
happening everyone please relax I think
you're gonna like this surprise guest
it's Saints it's gonna be saying Oh get
out skeleton man I'm so sick of these
haters we haven't missed amazing dude
how do you feel why is it it mean to
just play a song for half a second not
even half a second you know your own
husband don't you
thank God you made the right choice
honey who are you
he sings he sings it's so bad but it's
still funny it doesn't get better than
this
a shadow time the melody that will draw
you in
oh oh come on can we get a full version
[Music]
wise family guy in sans megalovania meme
out of all things that could become a
meme dank memes get that everybody
YouTube's show sponsored by her Milvian
next meme everybody what meme is he
going to kill mix like this show is just
add an execution at this point who is he
going to kill next all the memes are
just sitting there sweating right now
but I can please I got plates not me
I've only had two days it doesn't matter
when you tell a slightly offensive joke
at the dinner table you
your brother the guest printer that is
supposed to print in black
I need magenta why does printers always
need freaking magenta it makes me so
angry I think I might gonna drop a diss
track on magenta I like to print this
document yep
it's in black and white all right I got
and since it's black and white you don't
need any colors to print it right that
makes sense to me then rent it
I need magenta why it doesn't make any
sense what's up with printers am i right
like why do they need magenta which is a
color tricky I hate you magenta stupid
magenta why do they need magenta to
print black and white that doesn't make
any sense
stretch like if you think that doesn't
make any sense black and white magenta
why fricking wine like I want to know
the science I mean I want to watch like
a 30-minute Vsauce video breakdown with
this Michael besides you do unique
colors to print the black-and-white
photo
I need magenta you're supposed to print
in black magenta here take your stupid
magenta get me sire
no her he's probably thinking about
other girls in magenta oh oh I didn't
know this had a skin on it that's epic
that makes sense now we have this new
technology thanks to our sponsor calcium
and milk where we can see how long a
meme is going to life let's roll the
wheel
[Music]
I'll give him a week I'll give him 11
minutes minutes that's a new record
congratulations magenta me printer
magenta is just a carbon copy of moth
slash lamp and it's going to be dead in
a week like every other mean basement
[Music]
always there's always these pessimistic
son of a guns that just wants to trash a
means for some reason but it's my fault
for some reason that means are dying
when it's this pessimistic people I
think they're smarter than everyone else
before seeing then please consider set
buying a male revue merch I think you
guys are really gonna like it it's
probably the most effective way to
support the channel and I appreciate it
it's the official meme review merch
designed by yours truly we have it in
blue without the back print we also have
a cheaper t-shirt version and of course
the Hat of the intellectual if you want
to prove your power level to the public
this is what you wear my name is
PewDiePie and you've just been named